la célèbre romancière françoise sagan
hospitalisé dans un hôpital de bogota en
colombie où elle se trouvait à
l'occasion dû voyage officiel du
président de la république qui l'avait
invité à l'acia le suivre en compagnie
d'autres personnalités
françoise sagan pourrait avoir été
victime du mal de l'altitude car la
capitale colombienne est situé à plus de
2600 mètres ajouté peut-être à cela les
effets de boissons alcoolisées que
françoise sagan aurait absorbé au cours
d'une réception officielle son état
jusqu'à ce soir était jugé très sérieux
par les médecins qui diagnostiquent une
influence à une insuffisance
respiratoire
mais françoise sagan il y à quelques
instants a repris normalement conscience
sur place à bogota et nos envoyés
spéciaux ont recueilli le témoignage du
ministre de la culture monsieur jack
lang je me rêve que j'avais des
nouvelles de mes d'attenté 35 ans oui
les médecins colombien nous ont rassurés
naturellement des précautions sont
prises les médecins columbia lui apporte
l'assistance je fais ce faire et
espérons
l'avis de courage aux rétabli il est à
la batterie en france une question qui
devrait résonner dans la journée est il
préférable pour elle d'être soignés sur
place
je crois qu'elle est très bien soigné
par les médecins selon via l'hôpital
militaire ici avocat vient alors
envisagé effectivement son retour en
france
une question du sahara ne me sert
rapidement aujourd'hui
mais quel type de malaise un type de
malaise cardiaque
l'athlète est bête un colombien et et
que françoise sagan fatigué sans doute
par le voyage s'est trouvé victime d'un
mal qui parfois atteints ce qui arrive à
bogota le mal de l'altitude même j'irai
au et la guerre sur le corps une
pression très forte et il arrive en
effet que les accidents de ce genre se
produit oui ce soir à l'instant même
l'hôpital de bogota indique que
françoise sagan est atteint d'un oedème
pulmonaire et d'une limitation cérébrale
temporaire cela dit dans les milieux
proches de l'ambassade de france on
envisage tout de même le rapatriement en
france de françoise sagan